hey what's up welcome back the GameSpot
stage right here at e3 2015 I'm
delighted to be joined by mr. NICU
producer overcoming say hey do my
friends and we were to talk about one of
those Kickstarter games I don't know if
you heard a Kickstarter apparently now
you can just place yeah you could just
put it on the conference now and it'll
earn two million dollars pretty quickly
that was amazing
it still hasn't caught up with mighty
number 9 though you guys it was three
point eight or some three point eight on
Kickstarter long and then on PayPal we
had about 220 thousand dollars so
overall four million dollars at the very
end but just knocked it over the edge I
like that that was pretty cool um and
what's cool about your game is that a
really proof of concept for when
Kickstarter works is that we're gonna
see it in September so you guys have
turned it around in in two years two
years a little bit less than two years
but um we really worked hard on it yeah
we really did and we've got some
gameplay we're gonna get to in a little
while and for those who don't know
anything I'm sure that there's not many
people who don't obviously and the the
lineage with Megaman and catching a few
a it just give us a sort of a back story
as to how this game came about so you
know you know who Nate has been making
action games for almost his entire
entire career and that's like what a
little bit less than 30 years now so you
know he's always being you know a huge
fan of the action games and he likes to
make them and I'm pretty sure you know
to these sites core games always know
back up his head and when our agent
brought up this idea of you know
starting a Kickstarter this is the first
place he wanted to do like let's do to
decypher games and then well gather from
there we'll see who should we you know
asking this game to be made from and
immediately he saw integrates yeah they
have been making 3d sites or games of
their own whole life and we also you
know talked with Tom pawn and much much
like you know guys you know those people
they are actually the original Mega Man
team in Hoonah himself so the original
team coming back to
I need to make this game excellent and
we're sort of used to Kickstarter and
here in the West in was this a game that
was being sold from Japan to like the
Western audience or its Kickstarter and
Oman today in Japan well not too many
people know kicks are the dabrander
picture in Japan but I think once we got
our project funded we had some immediate
media coverage on Yahoo you or you know
those are websites so now people are
kind of know about Kickstarter and also
they have of their own you know
crowdfunding system in Japan and swap so
I think more people kind of know this
thing about Kickstarter and I think you
know a couple weeks ago a project just
ended their Kickstarter it's called a
bus thing but yeah code Igarashi so you
know more people more Japanese devs are
trying I think looking into kickstart
now for sure and the way we saw a lot
more of it on Sony stage of course as we
talked about earlier that one yes I
think we have we bought high five
dropped twenty nine dollars on that of
you know before I came to e3 I just like
blood stain I just bought that one and
now shaming comes around I was like come
on have to wait four years ago all these
games September and we're looking at it
in action right now so yes talk us
through exactly what receipt so right
now I think of wheel cars playing
backstage this is the intro stage of the
game it's basically the story on stage
and it should be the easiest stage to go
through this in this stage where you
learn the basic controls and then you
know the basically you know game flow of
the game and I think the core what the
base of the game is we added this future
called the absorption - basically you
shoot enemies a couple times and then
they'll change color and that's when
they're kind of stunned so when that
happens you wanna you know use your - -
towards them absorb their powers and
then that's the easiest way to defeat
enemies but also at the same time it'll
be the players were kind of risking
getting hit in cross-range
so there's all that that you know risk
versus the reward kind of thing
so if you want you know get higher
scores you want to absorb them as soon
as possible yeah so now you see you know
the numbers popping up on the enemy's
head the one hundred percent ninety
percent that's you know hot that's
showing that how fast you absorb that
enemy so if you want you can actually
chain all the enemies at 100 percent
throughout the whole stage and by then
you get like 100 percent of the ocean
light right and you know I'm pretty sure
the hardcore fans will you know compete
with that yeah and if fluence games have
never been well they've sort of been
scalable like it easy to pick up and
play but aim for so did you expect that
the super hardcore players will have
that level of difficulty to sort of
expire day they will meet their
challenges for sure I mean this is only
the normal difficulty level we also have
hard and hyper which is even harder and
then we just added this new level of
difficulty level it's called maniac what
it does is basically you'll die with one
shot
how many kind of damage you will kill
you right there what is their fault I'm
a Jersey okay I'm fall damage any kind
of damage any damage
you'll receive you'll die somebody looks
at you and there is the will powers just
died by the spikes you never beat the
spikes and have bigger we talk in terms
of the game and I have any different
sort of areas how many different
aesthetics so we have in total of 12
stages and eight bosses for the first
eight stages and then after you get
passed through you get into a different
type of stages and you actually get one
different playable character how cool
the call the kind of hearing of the game
and her gameplay is fully different from
what we're seeing with the bags that
game play some sort of robot cash
situation yes and if you look at the the
life bar of the boss the life bar isn't
actually decreasing and it's all that
there with bosses you actually have to
absorb them live to actually defeat them
so once the ball toss change color you
actually have to absorb - towards them
absorb their powers oh wow if you don't
do it in fast enough they will actually
kill that amount of damage escapes to
them and become you know healed again so
for every boss you have to do that I
know it kind of sounds you know crazy
and you know a lot of work to do but
once you start doing it you'll really
see why we put it in there because we
want players to take the risk getting
close range with the boss
yeah and absorb their powers so you
actually have to time yourself see the
distance between yourself and the boss
so it's all about you know getting close
and personal with the boss yeah I'm
presumably with with imprudence previous
titles variety and boss fights and sort
of has you unlock abilities and skills
right at bringing those into the fray
it's not very much the same yes
basically you will gain the boss's
ability once you beat them and you know
you can use them against different
bosses also as well as you can use them
in throughout the stage some of the
stage actually require you to use some
of the bilbies - you know some of the
puzzles so you know you're not using the
abilities against the boss and you're
using that in the stage as well and what
was it like working with the Kickstarter
backers because I remember I was keeping
an eye on the project and over the past
two years and they're often times were
you guys were even setting up votes on
what character models should be in yes
should be in the game what was that
process like have involved where the
backers in in decreased oh you know he
has been saying that he wants to make
you know the kind of games with back
it'll not backers but fans together yes
and this is it's pretty much well you
know that dream came true so we had
throughout the whole Kickstarter
campaign we made updates on what's going
on with the project every day and after
the camera every day it was brutal what
happens what happens if it was like the
day before you guys were just out on the
town had a couple of beers you just want
to do anything that day nobody was
really drinking a single drop of alcohol
throughout the whole campaign it's good
your launch party's gonna be now now you
kind of bring it back to you at the
nightmare so I'm saying oh my nightmare
because I have to work from you know ten
o'clock until say eight or nine nights
and go home have some dinner and you
know get myself shower have about maybe
two hours of sleep and then wake up
around twelve o'clock and midnight
starting working within the states
oh really because it's different to
different time zones yes we I have to
check all the updates that we're putting
up the next day I have to actually
translate all this stuff to go back to
bed then and then wake up again yeah oh
my god so I'm I work will end around you
know 3 or 4 a.m. I sleep or for you know
three hours four hours wake up drugging
myself to the office and starting
checking things and you know organizing
these and stuff I did that for the whole
month I guess that's what it takes to
get a kick starter game out in under two
years if somebody like you who's willing
to get up in my job and now I'm we're
teaming up with you know Deep Silver
which is located in Germany even worse
now where German as well no I don't I've
seen you know no now I'm kind of working
you know with three times different time
zones before my you know my flight to e3
I was working you know before you know
before e3 it's always chaotic totally
four years III I was the Thursday I was
working until 10:30 in office got back
home around 11:30 dinner shower and then
I started packing my bag 43 and then
around 303 4:00 a.m. we started
recording for the DLC on my night of
Dawa has that was five hours of work
great I had to go through on skype and
then I do I recorded I staying that
recording for five hours I was like dead
by the end
Nick you you look surprisingly fresh for
somebody who's just done all that work
like you so much for coming on our stage
and showing off mighty number 9 a dad in
September
what days and Alma platforms so platform
I'll give you the short version
everything and hopefully say them on the
date for my name night is September 15
for North America and then September 18
for worldwide and for the platform we
have you know Steam PC Mac and Linux and
ps4 ps3 xbox 360 Xbox one Wii U at the
same time great September and for the
handhelds it's gonna take a little bit
longer than you know the the consoles
because you know it's more work it's not
just porting we actually have to remake
most of the stuff for the handhelds so
that's gonna come a little bit later
than that awesome and hopefully you'll
enjoy your launch party Nikki thank you
so much thank you very much appreciate
your time